thank you Ada good morning and can I
just start by seeing what a pleasure is
to welcome you all to Edinburgh we've
already heard from two of the people who
are going to be crucial in reshaping our
country so that it's fit for the future
from Ed miliband who will ensure that we
take the necessary action to avert the
climate catastrophe and from Rachel
Reeves who will be a phenomenal
Chancellor for our country and who will
make sure we have a secure economy that
works for working people but all of this
all of this is only possible if we elect
a UK labor government led by my friend
Kier starmer
[Applause]
a UK labor government those who are
working people back in the driving seat
and that labor government is more
important than ever because across
Scotland people are living with the
failures of two bad governments we are
facing the twin crises of a cost of
living crisis where people are
struggling to put food on the table and
in any test crisis where people are
struggling to access life-saving NHS
treatment
we have two governing parties in
meltdown modern Scandal and division all
while energy bills and mortgage payments
rise
every hour families across the country
are plunged deeper into poverty and
tonight in this great City and indeed
across the UK there'll be mums skipping
meals to make sure they can feed their
children
and despite all this and more the SMP
say it doesn't matter if the Tories win
again
it may not matter to them but it matters
to the people of Scotland who are
dealing with soaring living costs and
falling wages it matters to the
businesses going to the wall because of
the tourist disastrous economic record
it matters to working people who are
seeing their hard-won workplace rights
eroded it matters to struggling families
who see Rising mortgages as a result of
the Tories crashing our economy and it
matters to the future of our planet as
we confront the climate emergency
because we must face a simple fact
our planet is at risk and the decisions
that this generation of leaders will
make will affect our children and our
grandchildren
the decisions we make today will decide
not just the future of Scotland and the
UK's economy but the future of the
planet and I am determined to leave our
children a better Planet than the one we
inherited
but to do this we need to remove both
these bad governments and deliver urgent
action because we are running out of
time
so what we are announcing today is the
boldest energy plan Scotland and the UK
has seen in Generations because the need
for bold thinking and big action has
never been greater we've been heeding
for well over a decade that we're going
to have a Green Revolution in Scotland
we've heard the promises before from a
UK touring government that talks big but
continually fails to deliver
and here in Scotland we've also had the
same broken promises from the SNP
some of you remember Alex salmon and
Nicola sturgeon promising to make
Scotland the Saudi Arabia of Renewables
but all they have delivered is an
industrial desert and even our seabed
has been flogged to foreign companies
and states on the cheap that's why it's
so important that we stop the rhetoric
because that frankly that's the easy
part what the people of the UK need
right now is not just politicians saying
the right things but actually doing the
hard work and delivering for our country
and labor is determined to do the hard
work and deliver but it's only possible
if we get rid of this economically
illiterate and morally bankruptory
government and we get rid of this
incompetent and dysfunctional SMP
government maximizing a Jobs first
transition must be more than just a
slogan for two failing governments it
has to be enshrined as part of our
national Mission and that's why the next
Labor government will deliver a real
green jobs Revolution
because we have four clear objectives we
will deliver lower bills not higher
bills we will deliver more jobs not
fewer jobs we will deliver greater
energy security so we do have to rely on
imports from despotic regimes like
Russia and we will deliver Global
Climate leadership because phrase there
is going to be a global leader in the
green Evolution why can't that be us why
can't that Global leader be Scotland why
can't that Global leader be the UK it
can be and it will be with a UK labor
government led by kierstarmer
should be
so the bull plans that we are launching
today will do more than just deliver a
clean energy Revolution by 2030. it will
deliver 50 000 clean Power jobs for
Scotland and it will deliver lower
builds for working people
and part of our plans include a publicly
owned clean energy generation company GB
energy and recognizing the significant
role that Scotland has to play in that
Revolution I am delighted to announce
that GB energy will be headquartered
here in Scotland
[Applause]
because
because this is a huge opportunity for
Scotland's economy and people right
across this country so don't let the SMP
tell you it doesn't matter who wins the
next election people across the country
know it matters it matters for
investment in our energy sector
particularly in the Northeast it matters
to people looking for well-paid and
high-skilled jobs that will last for
generations and it matters to every
family wondering how they'll pay their
skyrocketing energy bills you see while
the smps pledge of a public Energy
company is for them another broken
promise labor will deliver GB energy
back by the strength of a UK treasury
based in Scotland and delivering for
every part of our United Kingdom because
a liberal government will unleash
Scotland's massive energy potential by
making those strategic Investments to
maximize our opportunities and bring
jobs and prosperity to Scotland and the
whole of the UK and as part of that plan
for Scotland we will deliver more clean
energy and we will deliver more jobs and
alongside that in Scotland we will
deliver more opportunities around
onshore and offshore wind solar hydrogen
and carbon capture to make sure every
Community can play its part in achieving
our ambitions
now our opponents will want to suggest
that our plans are in conflict with the
Ambitions of the energy sector in the
northeast of Scotland nothing could be
further from the truth
so let me say this clearly there will be
no Cliff Edge there will be no turning
off of the Taps oil and gas will play a
significant role in our energy sector
for decades to come but what people
working in our oil and gas industry need
is a government that backs them that
works in partnership with them to
actually deliver a Jobs first transition
because we know that the public sector
can only do so much making the UK a
clean energy super problem will yes
require investment from government but
it will need an even greater investment
from industry and that's why we will
build that genuine partnership with
business to deliver for people across
Scotland and across the UK because labor
will not make the same mistakes the
Margaret Thatcher made when it came to
the mining industry she decimated the
sector many people lost their jobs and
livelihoods and many never went on to
work again so this is a labor plan that
will deliver what's right for Aberdeen
what's right for the Northeast what's
right for Scotland and what's right for
every part of the UK and that is a high
skill well-paid jobs for generations to
come
for too long people across this country
have had to live with an energy Market
that has failed to deliver the next
generation of jobs failed to deliver
security and has ended up costing
families the Earth
people across Scotland and the UK
deserve better people are crying out for
Change and only a labor government can
deliver it only labor can remove the
story government only labor can offer
unity and ideas by the s p loses its way
only labor can tackle the cost of living
crisis bring down bills and deliver the
jobs of the future only labor believes
that our country's best days lie ahead
of us it's time for change and we are
ready to deliver that change for
Scotland for the UK and our planet thank
you
it's
it's now my immense pleasure to
introduce the man that will deliver our
country's ambition will deliver Labor's
Mission our next prime minister
kierstarmer
thank you Rachel thank you Ed for your
introductory remarks and everything that
you're doing on this Mission thank you
anas for your remarks but also for your
leadership here in Scotland and be under
no Illusions here the tide is turning
here in Scotland and that's why I'm
delighted to be here in Leith to launch
the labor party's National mission on
clean energy
a call that will create good jobs
well-paid jobs half a million new jobs
50 000 here in Scotland will power us
forwards towards net zero generate
growth right across the country and the
suffocating cost of living Crisis get
Putin's boot off our throat with real
energy security
a stronger more secure Britain once
again but the service of working people
with cheaper bills and clean electricity
by 2030.
[Music]
it is an ambitious goal it will put us
ahead of any major economy in the world
but at the moment we're nowhere near the
front of the pack and this is a race we
have to win
the biggest opportunity we've had in
decades to make the country work for
working people
and this is always the test for labor
the purpose of my labor party all the
changes we've made are for this
to face down an age of insecurity
protect serve and deliver for the
aspirations of working people
[Applause]
and we relish
relish we embrace the harsh light of
clear accountability that's the that's
the challenge we choose with mission-led
government
and we do it
questions here
questions I'll be frank that are being
asked of all of us
being asked of Britain
can we still achieve great things
can we unite and move forward can we can
we change can we can we grow can we get
things done can we build things
new Industries new technologies new jobs
will they come to our Shores
or will the future pass Us by
you can put it even more starkly
around the world
people want to know
are we still a great nation
and look if the question is about the
British people the answer is
emphatically yes
but if it's about British politics
I don't need to even answer that do I
this is what we're taking on
the labor offer at the next election a
new government and a new way of
governing
a plan for change a plan to use clean
power to build a New Britain a plan to
get our future back and say to those who
doubt that we can still be great we are
we can and we will
[Applause]
but also that we must
and that the creative genius of Scotland
is critical to our prospects
I'll start with the necessity
the unbending urgency of this mission
it's not just about the imperative of
the climate emergency
not just the fundamentals of global
economic competition the race for the
jobs of the future it's all of that
absolutely
but it's also something even more
serious
make no mistake we are living in an
increasingly volatile world
the twin risks of climate change and
energy security Now threaten the
stability of Nations
so we've got to ground everything we do
in a new insight that clean energy is
NOW essential for National Security
our allies in the White House in
particular
have been crystal clear about this
and the war in Ukraine shows the
argument with total clarity
it's asking deep and difficult questions
of all of us
and I fully accept
especially here
fossil fuel energy plays a huge role in
the Scottish economy
it's also part of the social fabric
communities depend on it the jobs it
provides good jobs for working people
they're precious
and I'm not going to give you a moral
sermon about the urgency of climate
change everyone gets that argument
no
what I offer is a plan
a new course through Stormy Waters a
bridge to a better future
[Applause]
let me put it this way
I've been right across this nation in
the past year
I've been to Wick Glasgow Inverness
kakoli rutherglen five Leith here today
and throughout all this
I see the Contours of three different
scotlands
blood for Scotland that the solidarity
of working people build that the labor
movement built the industrial strength
the sense of community the social
housing the welfare state the NHS all
emerging out of the rubble of the second
world war all providing security for
working people in defiance of a volatile
world
but there's also the scars of the second
Scotland
a Scotland born of 1979 onwards
when the labor party was turfed out of
power in part it has to be said by the
SNP and the Tories got to manage that
period of enormous upheaval
it's a Scotland where the prosperity oil
and gas could have brought was
squandered on a political war against
that first Scotland
where the government saw working-class
solidarity across Britain as a threat
not a source of Hope and dynamism
and an economic transition away from
Scotland's main industries was
as it was in Sheffield and Sunderland
Nottinghamshire and Neath
chaotic unstable
brutal
but if you come to places like Nova
Innovation here
all the hydrogen and carbon capture
cluster in grangemouth
the Marvel of Whitely Wind Farm outside
Glasgow
then you can glimpse a different path
the green shoots of a third Scotland a
New Scotland a future Scotland
a Scotland that is once again the
Beating Heart of Britain because Britain
is once again built for and by the
solidarity of working people
so
let me say directly to those people in
Scotland nervous about the change this
Mission requires
I know the ghosts industrial change on
Earth
as a young lawyer I worked with the
mining communities to challenge the
tourist pit closure program
but deep down
we all know
this has to happen eventually
and that the only question is when
so in all candor
the reality is this
the moment for decisive action is now
if we wait until North Sea oil and gas
runs out the opportunities this change
can bring for Scotland and your
community will pass Us by
and that would be a historic mistake
an error for the future of Scotland as
big as the Thatcher government closing
down the coal mines while fructuring
away the opportunity of the North Sea
[Applause]
my offer the labor offer is this
a credible plan to manage the change to
protect good jobs create good jobs no
Cliff edges
but at the same time to harness the
wealth that's in our air our seas and
our skies and use it to serve the
interests of your community
because what's true in Scotland is true
right across the Grassroots of Britain
we can use the opportunity of clean
energy to create jobs to deliver
security bring back hope to communities
that got ripped apart by the
de-industrialization of the 1980s
this is a future we can win
but I also have to warn you
politicians are saying exactly the same
thing to their people in northern France
in Eastern Germany the Rust Belt of
America
now
tremendous advantages here
our Coast our shallow Waters our
universities our creativity
the depth of our skills The graft of our
people the super power Sciences the
technological Edge and yes if you can
believe it even our weather
Financial strength here in Edinburgh
and yes in the city of London too I know
but nonetheless the world leader for
green finance a massive Advantage for
all of us
seriously there are no grounds for the
defeatism which says we can't lead the
world on this
that our prospects will always be
squeezed out by the U.S and the EU
that's decline is nonsense
but at the same time
we've got to get moving
and at the moment we're standing on the
sidelines ringing our hands
falling behind because our government
talks about economic stability
yet understands nothing of what this
requires in times like ours
when the Winds of Change are blowing
this fiercely
you need a government that gets involved
that intervenes on behalf of working
people to secure stability and growth
drift equals chaos
this is about Tory ideology of course it
is
their impulses are totally out of step
with the challenges of the modern world
they still cleave to a set of ideas that
came out of the 1980s
the dismissal of industrial strategy
contempt for act government
says only the market decides which
Industries matter for working people and
National Security
you cannot understate this those ideas
are finished they can't cope with the
world where other countries simply don't
behave in the way market Dogma expects
the world now knows that crucial Global
Supply chains can be weaponized by
tyrants
but a sticking plaster approach to
investment will only cost more in the
long run
and that for working-class communities
trickle-down economics means power
trickles up and jobs trickle out
as Jake Sullivan President Biden's
National Security adviser put it this is
the new consensus
but Rishi sunak is blind to it he's
standing still
stubbornly Clinging On to the ideas of
the past as the opportunities of the
future slip through our fingers
I won't let that happen this cannot be a
rerun of the 1980s we've got to seize
the new opportunities this is the race
of our lifetime and the prize is real
we can cut bills create jobs and provide
energy security for Britain that's what
a labor government will deliver
that means we need to invest of course
it does
and look I know this comes with
challenges
political yes the British people always
need to know they can trust labor to
spend their money wisely
but also economic
because there are no shortcuts no easy
escape from the damages the Tories have
done to our public finances the wreckage
of the past 13 years
we'll need to be ruthless when it comes
to our priorities
and we must accept without complaint the
constraints of fiscal responsibility
it won't be easy
but
but if you look at the fiscal rules that
Rachel set out nearly two years ago
they've proved
not just resilient to the growing Tory
chaos
but also far-sighted
long before the starting gun was fired
Rachel and Ed anticipated the race we
must win
understood also that this is about
protecting our interests
that if your energy security relies on a
volatile fossil fuel Market
that leaves you exposed
and that all this must be built on a
rock of economic stability
so I say again
everything in our Manifesto will be
fully costed
day-to-day spending will be completely
covered by the taxes we collect
and we will get debt as a share of our
economy Falling by the end of the next
Parliament these are iron rules and we
must accept the consequences
because if you lose control of the
economy
it's working people who pay the price we
cannot let that happen
[Applause]
this is the bread and butter of
responsible government
our rules were essential for the British
people and investors in our country
and let me be clear
our plans to borrow for the
infrastructure of Tomorrow come firmly
within these rules in fact they will
save our public finances money in the
long run
if we fail to move quickly on this
we will increase debt as a share of our
economy by 23 percent
the Obama have already said that
the Tories can test it but but look
around the country this is part of the
problem sticking plasters everywhere
I'll give you an example
green crap
that's what they said
cut the green trap
and so they scrapped investment in home
insulation stalled nuclear energy bad
onshore wind
and the result
when the crisis hit last year
when Russia invaded Ukraine not only did
the Bills of businesses and working
people go through the roof we had to
borrow 40 billion pounds with no new
infrastructure to show for it that's not
green crap that's Tori crap
[Applause]
yeah
seriously it doesn't fix the Leaky Roof
when the sun is shiny it ignores the
roof and hopes it doesn't rain
so so don't tell me this is a global
crisis hitting every country the same
it isn't
time and again we get hit hardest and
sticking plaster politics is why
so yes we will borrow to invest we'll
invest to save for new jobs new
technologies new Industries in working
class communities for cheaper bills and
National Security
for a plan that will harness the
opportunity of clean energy and make
this country work for working people
[Music]
this isn't some kind of sackcloth and
sandals message anymore it's not a nice
to have
clean British energy is cheaper than
fossil fuels three times cheaper that's
a potential gold mine for our mission on
growth
and the benefits flow primarily to
working people and working-class
communities
I went to the steelworks in scumthorpe
two weeks ago and spoke to the workforce
there
now they don't glue themselves to
railings
but but let me tell you
they're desperate for change
they say we want clean energy we've got
the customers we just need the
technology and a government that stands
alongside us
it's the same story in Clyde Bridge same
story in Port Talbot these jobs are on
the line
so let's back carbon capture let's
invest in hydrogen nuclear tidal energy
double onshore wind treble solar power
quadruple offshore wind insulate 19
million homes
[Applause]
this is the new foundation for British
prosperity
1400 pounds a year off energy bills for
Working Families just imagine the
difference that will make in a cost of
living crisis
but to truly maximize the economic
benefits
we need to go beyond investment we've
got to roll up our sleeves and start
building things
run towards the barriers the planning
system the skill shortages the investor
confidence the grid if the status quo
isn't good enough we must find the
reforms that restart our engine
I'm not going to accept a situation
where our planning system means it takes
13 years to build an offshore wind farm
I'm not going to let slow connections to
the National Grid hold back 200 billion
pounds worth of projects and I'm not
going to allow other countries to build
the British infrastructure of Tomorrow
When those jobs belong in our country
no we're going to throw everything at
this planning reform procurement
long-term Finance r d a strategic plan
for skills and Supply chains a new plan
for a new settlement a clear Direction
across all four nations pulling together
for a simple unifying priority British
power for British jobs
[Applause]
they're going to be skeptical about this
I get that
especially here in Scotland
people say
we've got the wind farms we've got the
hydroelectricity we've invested in clean
energy
that's all good
but the job spoon we were promised
it never came
there's no denying this it's a fact
Oria simply era has failed miserably
less than a quarter of the jobs that the
SMP promised have materialized
simple reason for this is they don't
have a plan never had a plan
in the case of tourists that believe in
plants
but at a deeper level
because neither of them are truly
invested in Scotland's success
for the SMP any Scottish tribe in
Britain is a threat to the Ultimate
Prize
while the tourists welcome such division
because they think it works for them
politically
look at them both now
look hard
the soap opera that continues to demean
Britain's reputation
what do they have to say to the
investors who tell me
this is great political comedy but we
don't see Britain as a stable investment
anymore
they aren't serious
to win this race we need new
institutions new infrastructure new
investors and above all a new mindset
a Relentless determination to unlock the
pride and purpose of the whole country
so today
three new steps all in the first year of
the next Labor government the building
blocks of our plan for a New Britain
one we will harness the Bounty of clean
energy and do exactly what the tourists
fail to do with North Sea oil and gas a
new National wealth fund
this will crowd in investment for the
projects that are critical for growth
the battery gigafactories the clean
steel plants the ports that can finally
handle large offshore wind parks
and crucially
will give the British people a stake in
the returns and businesses the stability
they need
spoke to people involved in the
Project's grain routes lately
they're ambitious clear about the
benefits of carbon capture
frustrated about the speed of progress
and they also clear about the missing
ingredient
political Clarity of thought from
government
this is what the government doesn't get
public investment crowds in private
investment provides long-term certainty
this partnership this is the game
changer there are billions upon billions
waiting to be unlocked opportunities to
create jobs right across the country in
manufacturing and in services
but we've got to move fast
so today we go further
the competition for clean energy
investment is fierce
and it will only get fiercer
all around the world our competitors are
developing new Frameworks to attract it
and you better believe it they are
rewriting the rules of their economies
to make sure it delivers good jobs
the American inflation reduction Act is
setting the pace
in seven months
they've created more jobs than we have
in seven years
but they're not the only ones
and in truth we've never been on this
pitch
Britain has the second largest offshore
wind capacity in the world a close
second only to China
yet across the North Sea in Denmark
they've got three times as many jobs how
do you explain that
how do you explain Scottish wind
turbines
built in Spain in Holland and Indonesia
as the workers in the fabrication yards
in Fife working people who would be
proud to build something great for their
country
look out of their window and watch
others putting them up on the fourth
there is no justification
but mark my words this ends with a labor
government
[Applause]
we will transform the way we set the
price for investors in clean energy
the contracts for different auctions
must deliver jobs as well as investment
we will set new rules as a condition of
entry on good work decent pay and Union
recognition
but we will also create a new incentive
a direct response to the quickening PACE
the world is setting on the jobs of the
future
a British jobs bonus that will attract
new investment new jobs new Supply
chains into our deprived industrial
Heartland
will reward companies that back working
people unlock the pride of the builders
bring security and hope back to
Britain's Grassroots
and finally the centerpiece
the embodiment of our new priorities and
values
a new homegrown Energy company
a benefit so many of our competitors
already enjoy like Earth did in Denmark
that and fall in Sweden
argument is simple
if there is money to be made from our
resources
it must serve the British people
must invest in our communities
create British jobs
[Applause]
right now Malaysia and Munich the city
of Munich owned more of our offshore
wind assets than we do
and this makes it so much harder for us
to turn clean British power into good
British jobs
no more
we will set up a proper National
Champion Great British energy
we will grow the industries of tomorrow
here the clean energy projects in every
community so we can win the race for the
future
and because it's right for jobs because
it's right for investing in our
communities because it's right for
National Security yes GB energy will be
publicly owned
and let me also be clear
GB energy will be a shared project owned
by all four nations on these islands
so we will set up a governance structure
that will protect its long-term future
whoever's in power in Westminster
whoever's empowering Hollywood
this will be the driving force for a New
Britain
its offshore wind in Scotland yes
but also in t-side North Yorkshire
Grimsby all the way down our East Coast
tidal energy here and in South Wales
clean hydrogen energy in Yorkshire
merseyside and grangemouth a National
Institution a common cause the benefits
of clean energy owned by the British
people shared by the British people
and because the skills are here
because this belongs to all of us
because of Scottish Ingenuity we will
base GB energy right here in Scotland
this is our plan our national mission
a down payment on a New Scotland a New
Britain a United Britain
a Britain built once again by the
solidarity of working people right
across these islands
it won't be easy
there are tough battles ahead on
planning on the grid on technology
prioritizing the right investment at the
right time in the right place that's
easy to say but hard to do
and the world is dynamic
we will need to run faster catch up
faster still to get ahead faster again
to stay there
but do not underestimate the power of
pride
the purpose people feel when they're
building a legacy for their community
working people in Scotland
working people across Britain are
looking at us again
they want to know if we get this
want to see if the fire of change still
Burns inside the labor belly and this is
our chance
the race of our lifetime for jobs for
growth for protecting our planet
National Security the aspirations of
working people getting our future back
and uniting our country again some
nation is going to lead the world in
offshore wind why not this one
some Nation will win the race for new
hydrogen power
why not us
some Nation will become a clean energy
superpower why not Britain thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you very much we're now going to
take questions from the media and Anna
is going to come and join me on stage to
take those questions
it's one each please and we're going to
start with Beth
Beth Rigby thank you um Beth Rigby Sky
News um Mr stormi you're making big
promises but you have already you turned
on your 28 billion pound a year
investment into green transition Your
Shadow Chancellor said it shows you can
be trusted with the public finances but
doesn't it also suggest as with brexit
tuition fees nationalizations you're
just like all of those other politicians
who can't be trusted to keep your
promises and on a broader political
question if I may you've chosen to be
here in Scotland today rather than sw1
Boris Johnson's out there could or
couldn't be a vote on him later while in
Scotland it seems that the SMP
Stranglehold is finally over Napoleon
said that generals need to be lucky and
you're clearly a lucky General surely
you can't possibly blow it now thank you
thank you Ben I think for the record
that was two questions but I've been
expected nothing less uh on the 28
billion we are doubling down we're not
backing off and it's really important
that we say this uh for two reasons for
the policy position we've adopted the
first is a matter of trust the very
thing you touch on Beth which is we said
that our fiscal rules were in place
Rachel set them out two years or more
ago inflation now is in a completely
different place to where it was two
years ago because the Tories have made
such a mess and done such damage to the
economy but at the same time as we work
through our plans and set out what we'll
do in years one two three showing just
how serious we are it's clear that we
can ramp up that 28 billion pounds and
what I would say Beth is this when I say
to um people in the sector that we will
partner with that we want clean Power by
2030. they don't say you're somehow
backing down or lacking ambition they
say whoa that is a real challenge
centrica say it's doable but we're
really going to have to go go for it so
there's nothing here to read into any
sense of lacking ambition or backing
down on the second question
um Beth um look
there's a reason that the tourists and
the s p are imploding and it's their
failure in government for a long time
they've been able to avoid any question
about their record and both of them are
now getting questions about their record
and you only have to look at the record
uh and ask the question and it's the
same question of the Tories or the SMP
which is after however many years in
power for each of them do you feel any
better off now than you did when they
started and the answer that question is
no and because it's no we can see the
impact it's having but what I would say
is this we know that we have to earn
every vote we know that we have to go up
again I've said to my shadow cabinet
we've got to be exceptional as we go
forward from here there is no right to
any vote anywhere in the United Kingdom
whether that's you know elsewhere or
here in Scotland we have to earn every
vote I'm I find some comfort in the fact
that the changes we've made to the labor
party both uk-wide and in Scotland put
us in a position where when people look
away from the tours in SNP and to the
opposition they see a change labor party
with answers to the challenges of the
future and I'll end with this doesn't it
speak volumes that the labor party is
today launching a plan for the next
generation of jobs whilst the tourists
are squabbling back in Westminster the
SMP are preaching about promises that
they have broken thank you very much
Beth we'll go to
James please James Cook BBC yes thanks
so much secure James Cook BBC news on
the facts first of all can you confirm
that the labor government would no
longer issue exploration licenses for
the North Sea but would allow drilling
licenses to continue to be issued in
existing fields and on the reaction to
that
oil industry bosses and trade unions
appear to be United in opposition to
your plans warning that they would chill
investment and cost jobs doesn't that
water you
but look James firstly thank you for
that question our policies directed
expiration licenses as you rightly say
the very early stage licenses and we're
very clear about that that equally means
that oil and gas will be part of the mix
for decades to come under existing
licenses well into the 2050s but and I
was trying to get at this in my speech
we've got to face the reality that this
is dwindling and we've got to be
absolutely clear that the transition is
on all around the world the discussion
in other countries about the power of
the future is about Renewables and
they're racing ahead the U.S is racing
ahead they're like a magnet for jobs and
investment the EU is responding and we
need to respond so this is a massive
opportunity to deliver lower bills not
just sticking plaster where it's just
for this year or next year with a
windfall tax that can't be sustained but
lower bills because Renewables are
cheaper energy security because Putin is
trying to put his boot on our throat and
oil and gas is sold onto the
international market so that doesn't
help reduce bills and the next
generation of jobs and you know when I
look back at what happened with the coal
mining communities with the coal fields
and look at the mistakes that were made
then not planning for the future Not
Having the courage to see the change
that was necessary not leading your
nation through that change
I am resolved that we will never repeat
that under a labor government we will
plan for that change but will ensure
that good quality jobs are available
here 50 000 in Scotland all across the
UK and in generations to come others
will look back and say that was a
reforming labor government that seized
the moment and secured our energy supply
for the future anas can I bring you in
on this one please brief Point James
first one is I can completely understand
the concern from industry and trade
unions because they have been promised
for the last decade and government
hasn't backed up that promise either
with investment partnership or forward
thinking and we're going to change that
you heard that from cure speech today
the second important to make is we're
really clear there is no Cliff Edge
there is no turning over the Taps and
oil and gas will play a significant role
for decades to come and the third point
is partnership partnership is crucial to
this we cannot do this alone we get a
mission-driven government from the Prime
Minister from the treasury but unless we
get that genuine partnership with
industry to Loop in that Strategic
investment that scale of investment
we're not going to deliver on this
ambition and we're going to be true to
that partnership great uh
Peter from ITV border Peter secure um
this document today says you're
committed not to hand out new licenses
to Oil and Gas
you also said in your speech that this
is a moment for a decisive action
so if you were prime minister today
would you give the go-ahead to the Rose
Bank field the logic of this document
surely is that you wouldn't so why not
say that now and be as you said in your
speech decisive and say if I become
Prime Minister I will not give the go
ahead I will send those licenses because
your document also says you want to
demonstrate climate leadership to
protect our planet for future
Generations a three million Barrel oil
field doesn't do that does it Peter the
position we've taken consistently on
this is uh no to new expiration licenses
but whether existing licenses and that
includes any that are granted between
now and the next election we're not
going to interfere with them we know the
impact that would have on investors and
we're not going to interfere with them
rosebank is probably up the decision
very soon now and if it's granted then
that falls into the category of existing
licenses but this is about the
opportunity that Renewables gives us the
opportunity for the next generation of
jobs and lower bills and energy security
and if we had taken just some of the
steps that we've set out today in the
last 10 to 15 years what Ed said in his
introduction we wouldn't be where we are
now we're in the middle of a cost of
living crisis which is bearing down on
working families across Scotland Working
Families across the whole the United
Kingdom because of the failure to take
the difficult decisions and we're not
going to fail to take those difficult
decisions this is a about the
opportunities of the future thank you
Peter I've got Fiona from the guardian
do we have them thanks
um Mr stammer um the chair of the
climate change committee called the
Tories Hypocrites because uh they're
handing out new licenses uh while
telling other countries not to
um but you're talking about continuing
to produce oil and gas here for decades
um now if all countries did that and
exploited their reserves like that we'd
go well beyond 1.5 degrees so by saying
that you're going to be asking other
countries to not exploit their their
reserves while we will exploit ours
doesn't that make you a hypocrite no we
I mean it's a very clear approach we've
taken which is whether existing licenses
obviously we'll work with the sector
under those licenses there'll be a mix
of oil and gas but there's got to be a
transition not least because oil and gas
is running out almost 90 percent of the
gas in the North Sea is already
accounted for it's either out or it's
already under license and therefore this
is a diminishing return and we have to
be ready for that transition and that's
why I said in my speech we have to seize
this moment and the ambition we've set
out for clean power clean electricity by
2030. is a really massive ambition we'll
change the nature of power generation in
this country and and we will not fall
behind other countries on our
obligations we'll get ahead of them but
in doing so we'll have you know lower
bills energy security and the jobs of
the future thank you Fiona and I'll go
to Gina of LBC
you know worried about their jobs there
are people worried about their homes
what is your message of reassurance to
people you know who are who are looking
at their the rents Rising their
mortgages Rising their energy bills
rising and can I ask this indeed for
investment from industry does that mean
no more windfall taxes on energy
companies by labor government
people can see the record profits you
made by the oil and gas giants and this
is unexpected profits because of what's
happened between Russia and Ukraine and
I think it's perfectly reasonable for us
to see in the face of a costal living
crisis where bills are skyrocketing and
companies are making those excess
profits that we do have that short-term
windfall tax on those excess profits so
we can put that money back into families
Pockets I can also give a research on
the first point I we cannot be any
clearer we are not going to make the
same mistakes as Thatcher did with the
mining industry we are not going to
decimate communities we are not taking
away people's jobs those jobs will stay
those jobs will support and will work
with the industry to do that meaningful
transition what we're talking about here
is a declining asset and what comes in
the face of that declining asset now we
can choose to let the asset deplete and
then choose to make the Investments when
it's too late in order to get that
transition or jobs or we can work in
Partnership to make those strategic
Investments so people can see with their
eyes what that transition looks like not
to have a blind promise great thank you
and I've got Rachel Watson from the Sun
on rosebank
excited to resent that license are you
just in effect letting the toys Do Your
Dirty Work if they do give it the go
ahead and also as has been said unions
and Industry are against your plans on
the North Sea oil license ban are there
any circumstances that you would Grant
you licenses in the National interest
well um look I I think I've been pretty
clear three or four times now in
relation to this in relation to existing
uh licenses and we're obviously talking
to and working with the unions talking
to him working with the sector I had a
round of discussions with the sector
last week and and I would say this about
both the unions and the sector
they really want to work with us on the
plan we're setting out today they want
to roll up their sleeves and work with
us on the renewals because they know the
Futures in Renewables talk to any of the
players in the sector and they're
already putting more in the Renewables
basket than they are in oil and gas so
they're already on this transition I
think this depiction of them sort of
over here
um only concerned with oil and gas and
Renewables of no interest is wrong
actually they're running towards it and
what they want is a government that
works with them and recognizes that as
we go forward and that's what we offer
them and we're looking forward to
working with them on it's got to be fair
it's got to ensure that
um you know the jobs of the future are
in the places and and that's why the
British jobs bonus is so important
because that is intended to ensure that
the jobs in the sector the supply chain
jobs in the sector are here in the UK
and in in Scotland this has felt very
very strongly which is yes we've got the
offshore wind but we didn't get the jobs
with it the supply chains are elsewhere
I went to whiteley's to that turbo in
the biggest turbine Factory wind farm in
Scotland actually in the UK
and every single one of the 350 turbines
was built elsewhere not a single one was
built in the United Kingdom and that's
why our British jobs bonus is so
important that is to ensure that those
jobs are here in the UK and in
particular targeted at the places that
most need that those industrial
heartlands it is the complete opposite
of what the tourists failed to do with
coal mining where they let something die
they had no plan for the future and
frankly we're still feeling that you
know decades later thank you very much
the four principles of energy policy
which we've all set out today
but we can be clear about this more jobs
not fewer jobs lower bills not higher
bills greater energy security not
greater energy insecurity and climate
leadership that are the four principles
that guide all of our energy policy
thank you and Rachel from the Scotsman
the phage and oil and gas book how long
can somebody who's working in that
industry expect to keep their jobs and
if there's somebody who is considering a
career in that industry just like would
you discourage them for from pursuing
that career well look absolutely no and
and those people are going to keep their
jobs I think it's really important to
stress that oil and gas is going to play
a significant role for decades to come
many of those rules are already starting
to be transitioned in terms of people
moving from my own gas we met many of
those workers for example in WIC that
previously worked in the oil and gas
sector but now work in our offshore wind
capacity so those jobs will be protected
what we want to do is work with industry
to make sure there is that pathway from
those oil and gas jobs longer term into
those Green Revolution jobs great Kieran
from the times thanks very much and this
morning journalists were promised a
hydrogen bus to bring them down here
today in fact what was waiting for them
was a diesel vehicle with a driver who
didn't know where they were going given
that and given that Weber appears to
have spent the last few weeks scorpioing
over the details of this after what an
ass called an unhelpful briefing to the
Sunday Times a few weeks ago
why should anyone trust labor to be
across the details to make these
ambitious plans work can I just first of
all say there's a hydrogen bus company
here so we'll uh I'm sure we'll talk to
them and make sure we're recruiting more
hydrogen buses across our public
transport infrastructure for every part
but I don't have care once they come
back on the on the wider point or The
Wider Point look
um you've got the team working on this
mission right here in this room all
speaking this morning all speaking with
one voice and this is an ambitious plan
which is set out in detail not only in
the various words that we've all said
this morning all complementing words by
the way but also in the document that
underpins it that sets out the nuts the
nuts and bolts
um and you know this is an exciting plan
for the future it shows
um a an opposition ready for government
already planning for government and
talking to the sector about how we
Implement these plans because what we
don't want to do is to get to the next
election and if we're privileged enough
to win it
um and it will be a privilege to curve
to then start our discussion so it's the
complete opposite Kieran of the picture
you've paid this is a strong plan it's
an agreed plan and we are already
talking to the sector about how we
implement it and across the sector they
want to hear that argument I can't we
went to scunthorpe um steelworks Ed and
I last week I'll give you just an
example of why this is so important
their customers want decarbonized Steel
and they can't produce de customized
Steel
the workforce want to change because
they want their jobs they want their
Factory their steel Works to survive and
it will only survive if they go through
this change so they're not saying to us
please save the jobs we've got
they're saying please help us have the
jobs now and for the future and that's
the level of Engagement that we're
involved in in the delivery of this plan
so I'm very confident this plan it's a
very United team as we go forward and I
think
um Kieran as you go through the document
which you probably haven't had the
chance to get the background document
you'll see it's a huge amount of detail
there about how we're going to implement
it
um David from the mirror yeah hi thank
you very much
um panel base at the weekend uh
predicted that labor would now win 26
seats in Scotland
um is this realistic do you think uh how
important is Scotland in your plans to
try and in the path to Downing Street
very quickly if I may given the events
in Westminster at the moment how do you
think history is going to judge Boris
Johnson and what impact is he uh
incoming elections is he likely to have
uh in terms of trusting politicians how
much of a challenge is it going to be to
win that back yeah just um David on on
the
um question of Scotland
um I'll leave the polls to anas
um
because I'm very very conscious of the
fact that
um for me there are two things that
matter because it matters to me it
matters to Labor uh Scotland is Central
to our planning as we go forward for two
reasons of course there's the fact that
we need seats in Scotland to win a
general election
but there's a secondary and really
important factor for me and that is if
we are privileged to serve
I want to be the Prime Minister not just
of the UK but for the UK and therefore I
want that representation here in
Scotland to bind together everything
that we do as an incoming labor
government for the whole of the United
Kingdom and one of the features of the
last 10 15 years has been divide divide
divide divide find points of difference
I want to be the Prime Minister leading
a labor government that legitimately
says we have representation across the
whole of the United Kingdom and we will
pull people together on the important
things that matter this mission is not
going to be achieved if we don't pull
together as all four nations
um and so yes it's a it's a question of
the number of seats but it's not a
mathematical calculation alone it's
something deep about what I want to
achieve if we are privileged enough to
serve as the next Labor government and
I'm prime minister for the UK not just
of the UK and as you you've been can I
see directly on the pools that we are
not complacent for a second and our feet
are firmly on the ground of course you
recognize its significant progress I've
probably still got a hell of a lot of
work to do and the hard work we've got
to do and we've had to do this curious
had to do this in the last three years
across the UK I've had to do it against
the last two years is first of all
demonstrate the labor party is changing
and is focused on the future not the
past
a second rebuild our campaigning
infrastructure so we're actually
reaching out and listening to people and
expressing their concerns third being
that credible opposition and I think we
have built that both across the UK and
here in Scotland where people can now
see how these two governments are
feeling us but the fourth and the most
important part and today is a huge part
of this is setting out not just why our
opponents deserve to lose but actually
why labor needs to and deserves to win
and why labor needs to and deserves to
win you can hear it in terms of taking
action on the cost of living crisis
delivering that Revolution and the green
technologies in Scotland and across the
UK for every part of our country so we
can have that energy security investment
in strong economy going forward and a
third crucial part is around the NHS
today the first minister of Scotland is
sitting at a Charter of Rights for an
independent country one of those rights
is Access to Health Care this is a first
Minister who was Health secretary and
who knows first Minister presides over
000 Scots waiting on an NHS waiting list
it's not acceptable it's not right so of
course we welcome the poll but we've got
a hell of a lot of work to do and we're
not complacent about that for a second
great thank you Alice and then finally
Andy from Preston Journal Andy hi to you
Kia please um the energy industry
workers and businesses in the northeast
of Scotland in particular are looking
for a statement of intent
um that several companies tell us that
they're worried about jobs having to be
cut because of policies such as windfall
taxes and we're in Leith today instead
of somewhere like Aberdeen
where we keep being drawn back to oil
and gas and transition so why and what
can you say to them and the offshore
workers there who worried about their
future and perhaps the GPA and the GP GB
energy HQ can be located there
we've not decided the location yet but
I'm sure I promise that is work that we
will be doing but I think it's important
I think you're right to make the point
about Aberdeen and I'll address
Aberdeen's in a second but I think it's
also important to stress that the oil
and gas sector is not just important to
Aberdeen if you look at these Supply
chains they go right across the whole of
the UK and jobs rely on that in every
part of the UK where we are right now is
the perfect example of that and the
promise I want to make to colleagues in
Aberdeen and to people that work in our
oil and gas sector renewable sector in
Aberdeen is this is a plan that is for
you and will work with you to deliver
for you this is not a plan that's bad
for Aberdeen I am confident that it's
good for Aberdeen it's good news for the
Northeast it's good news for Scotland
and it's good news for every part of the
UK and the promise we make is we're not
going to just talk from two parliaments
one either Investments or one from
Hollywood about what happens in
individual communities we promise we
will be out there built having those
conversation and working in partnership
with those Industries for to deliver and
you'll be seeing ourselves in Aberdeen
I'm sure not the not too distant future
thank you all very much for coming this
morning thank you very much
I think we're